everyone welcome to this live Q&A
session as I set myself up here it is
good to see all of you metaphorically
speaking thank you for joining as I
think many of you know this is a series
that we've been doing now for a couple
weeks
kind of informal discussion of the big
ideas of physics the ones that have
really transformed our understanding as
well as some of the big ideas in
mathematics and sometimes where the
physics and math comes together and the
goal is to give not just the popular
level description of things but to go a
little bit further in the series your
daily equation that's what I've been
doing in the individual episodes but in
this live Q&A I'm happy to frankly go
anywhere any questions that you may find
of interest so I'm gonna jump right in
I'm taking questions from the live
YouTube feed in fact you know as I'd
like to do in these you know just chime
in and tell me where you're you're
watching from where in the world that's
always fun for me to see so I'm taking
questions from the YouTube feed and also
from Twitter and Facebook as well so I'm
gonna jump right in on the first
question that I have here from rob
shovel and again sorry I know that I
always get the names
pronounced wrong but Rob says sometimes
here scientists say that it is probable
that life exists elsewhere in the
universe but for life we only have a
sample size of one the earth isn't it
unscientific to make probabilistic
claims with a sample size of one and my
temptation is to say Rob you're
absolutely correct
we have virtually no data if you will in
terms of how prevalent life might be in
the cosmos since we as you say only have
this one data set namely here on planet
Earth we sometimes hear people talk
about the Drake Equation which is meant
to be an equation that describes a
likelihood of finding life elsewhere in
the cosmos but if we've ever looked at
the Drake Equation it's not an equation
in any real sense it's simply an
encapsulation of the factors that will
affect whether or not there is life in
the universe and it's a multiplication
of the various likelihoods or not of
having a planet that can host life or
having the necessary conditions for life
or the various other things that need to
come together for life to exist it's
kind of a way of encapsulating our
ignorance about whether or not there is
other life in the universe so there's no
real way to say there's a 32% likelihood
of life out there in the cosmos now the
only reason that unqualified manager
slightly as I will write now is that on
planet earth we do have a lot of
different forms of life we think they
all started in the same place but but
that's allowed us to at least gain some
insight into the conditions necessary
for our kind of life and with that
insight we can then look out into the
cosmos and ask ourselves do we find
other worlds out there at the level of
which we can measure their properties
from here on planet Earth
our
other worlds out there that seem to have
the conditions that we believe are
necessary for life to exist and evolve
and that's a that's a totally scientific
study and a totally scientific question
but since we don't know the full list of
ingredients and the full list of
conditions necessary for life to emerge
at the moment you're absolutely right we
cannot make any definitive statements
whatsoever about the likelihood of life
elsewhere in the cosmos like everybody
I've begun feeling there's a lot of
space out there a lot of room out there
it makes you feel like there has to be
life out there but let's think about it
if the odds of life forming were so
incredibly tiny then no matter how big
the space isn't how many planets are out
there if it was sufficiently small it
wouldn't be enough for there to be life
beyond planet Earth okay on to question
number two here what are the
implications of a multiverse a yang from
YouTube acts asks not acts what are the
implications of a multiverse with
respect to death and consciousness if
there was another meet and another
universe would I experience it when I
die could I wake up in another universe
and yeah that's a deep question and the
the quickest answer is if there is a
multiverse big if many reasons for
taking that idea seriously but you need
to know it's quite hypothetical and if
the version multiverse is come in mini
from version if the version of the
multiverse allows there to be another
version of you out there in another
world another realm that might be
parallel to this one that you might have
had the same experience as you and have
the same thought processes as you have
the same genetic makeup molecular makeup
atomic makeup quantum mechanical wave
function description as you at a given
moment in time but it's still an
independent being living in a distinct
world that happens to be say an
identical copy of you now if the way
reality unfolds in the different you
versus allows for you to die in this
universe and to live in that universe
that's nice in that there's another
individual in the totality of reality
that has all the thoughts feelings
sensations memories as you do who's
carrying on in that other realm even
though you in this realm are not
carrying on but the you who's here would
really be gone it's not that you would
wake up in the other realm you here
are confined to the physical
architecture and the psychological
architecture that makes you you here and
if that goes away then you go away here
but you can still find some consolation
in recognizing that there's a version of
you a person who has the same thoughts
memory sensations of feelings who is
carrying on and that can offer some
degree of Solace if you believe in this
multiverse perspective let's see from
another YouTube question take vex
Simonian hello professor Greene well
hello Tate Vick have you ever tried to
find explanation of the Mandela effect
is it a glitch in the system or parallel
universe is merging into another from
Armenia you know I I once looked up what
this Mandela effect is maybe somebody
can remind me in the YouTube comments
what it is it struck me at the time when
I looked at it as kind of nonsense but
I'm having trouble remembering it and
that's probably why I'm not remembering
it because it didn't make an impression
on me but let's see if I can get in the
chat here somebody who wants to to tell
me about what that is and I'm happy to
to respond to it if it seems sensible
but I'm gonna leave that for now and go
on to Dave Nadel Borges question and
this is from Twitter I recall cuz I saw
this just a little while about a few
minutes ago my 14 year old son and I
were wondering is there anything in the
universe that is not moving is anything
actually at rest I told him I'd ask you
recently read the fabric of the cosmos
job making it somewhat attainable for
the everyman like oh thank thank you
Dave and your fourteen-year-old son it's
a great question is there anything that
is not moving well the key thing to
recognize is there's no absolute
standard of rest in the universe as far
as we know all you can ever talk about
is something moving relative to
something else and so in that sense if
you ask is anything actually arrest I
would say well you have the right to
claim that you are at rest especially if
you are not feeling a force on your
bodies that's a little bit more
technical but we learn from both Newton
and Einstein and Galileo in various
distinct ways of framing the the
principle if you're not experiencing a
force then you are in what's known as an
inertial frame and that allows you to
claim that you are at rest and anything
else that you see moving is moving
relative to you you set the standard of
rest and therefore there isn't in that
sense a universal standard it's each and
every one of us can claim to be that
standard now the one thing I will
quickly say and that is when we measure
the cosmic microwave background
radiation we find that it has a
uniformity the heat left over from the
Big Bang has uniformity only if we're
looking at it from a certain frame of
reference
the one that we believe is the the most
useful and the simplest perspective with
which to analyze the cosmos and so you
could take that frame of reference in
some sense to be the standard of rest
but again as I was saying the reality
from fundamental physics is that anybody
in an inertial frame of reference can
claim to be at rest all right
Joshua Wakefield and this is another
Twitter question I'll come back to the
YouTube list for the next one what are
your thoughts on Wolfram's result on a
theory of everything that he just
believed yeah so Steve Wolfram it was um
you know a friend of mine tonight I've
known for a very long time brilliant
individual as you all know he he came up
he was a physicist and then he moved
into more into the computer realm and
developed the whole Mathematica
computing system which has
revolutionized the way many of us do our
calculations and of late he's returning
to physics and believes that he has a
new framework for developing a more deep
understanding of physical law and I
can't really respond to it because I've
not had the time to study it and in a
detail I quickly thumbed through it when
it was released on Tuesday he alerted me
to it being released and I was thrilled
to take a quick look but I haven't had
the time to really dive into it so so I
don't know but you know it's always
exciting when when a deep thinker
proposes a new way to approach questions
that we have struggled with for a very
long time so I'm looking forward to
gaining a deeper understanding of what
Steve is is thinking and and who knows
maybe it will give some insight that
we've yet to achieve in any other way
all right so from YouTube
a question from Narendra s string theory
is possibly in the existence of
gravitons and treating gravity as a
force won't this go against relativity's
idea of gravity's the consequences of
curvature of space-time
right so um so the question that
Narendra is asking is in the general
theory of relativity which we've not yet
covered in any of the episodes of your
daily equation but I think I'm gonna get
to it maybe next week or the week after
we'll talk about the curvature of
space-time and the metric tensor and the
Riemann curvature tensor and so forth
but for now just keeping it loose
Einstein says that gravity is associated
with warps and curves in the fabric of
space-time and then he says you know
when when you have an object you know if
I if I have an object and I drop it
what's really happening is the object
itself is sliding along an indentation
in the fabric of space-time so it's not
it's not really a force anymore it's
really the geometry of the universe that
simply guides objects to travel along
the path of least resistance for them
which from our perspective makes it look
like they are falling but in reality
what I said really says is if an object
is falling it is providing the standard
of rest to go back to an earlier
question and if you put your mindset in
the frame of reference of the following
object and everything else in the world
looks like it's moving upwards so in
reality from the standpoint of the did
the Apple pencil here I'm shooting in
the upward direction and it claims to be
at rest so it's all about the geometry
of the universe go back to neurons
question how does that relate to the
idea of a force being transmitted by a
particle which is what quantum mechanics
tells us right the electromagnetic force
is transmitted by the photon a particle
that goes from here to here and
communicates the electro magnetic force
for gravity we haven't ever found a
graviton but the belief is that gravity
is also transmitted by a quantum of
gravity called the graviton and so how
do you relate these two pictures well
the example of the electromagnetic force
really helps us out so light an
electromagnetic wave is the way the
we began to think about the
electromagnetic properties enforced back
in the 1800s now an electromagnetic wave
have you realized back to photons answer
when you have a huge number of photons
moving in a nice choreographed
coordinated manner those particles can
fill out a wave much like h2o molecules
when moving in a nice coordinated manner
fill out a water wave so when you have
enough of the particles enough of the
quanta they can closely approximate the
image of a nice smooth wave and so for
gravity the idea would be the same if
you have a sort of nice wavy shape to
the fabric of space in some sense it's a
collection of gravitons that fill out
that wavy shape it's a very peculiar
kind of quantum state called a coherent
state that yields this wave-like shape
in space for a force like gravity or
force like electromagnetism but that's
the way you can go back and forth
between these
wavey language so they really can be
made compatible even though it's for a
site they do seem completely different
let's see Kadapa
dip fee ask is there something like
girdles incompleteness theorem in
physics that's a that's a tough one and
the quick answer is I'm I'm not I don't
know if there really is because I don't
know the right assumptions to make for
the final physical description of the
universe you see when you're doing
mathematics you the user the
mathematician sets the ground rules and
so when when girdle was working on his
incompleteness theorem which I should we
mentioned saying there can be true
statements within a mathematical system
that are beyond the system's ability to
decide that they are true so so so they
can be correct and yet unprovable within
the system of mathematics itself now
girdle was making certain basic
assumptions about the axioms of the
mathematical system within which he was
able to prove this incompleteness
theorem among those is or the standard
kinds of logic that that we all make use
of but when it comes to a physical
theory you the user you don't set the
axioms of the ground rules the universe
reality does and so for instance people
have put forward the possibility that
the correct logic for talking about the
physical universe might be what's known
as a para consistent logic it's a
slightly different logic than you're
familiar with in an ordinary logic you
can have a or not a you can have
something to be both true and not true
right that would be inconsistent that
would be something that doesn't make any
sense but there are different kinds of
logic in which you can have a and not a
both true but it doesn't mean that their
union is true and it doesn't mean that
any of the ordinary conclusions that you
would draw from something and not
something both being true which usually
makes the whole logical edifice
collapse impaired consistent lodging you
can make the edifice still stand even in
that sort of situation and in that kind
of logic the incompleteness theorem
actually wouldn't go through at least
certainly not in the same mode with the
same force and therefore you could
imagine that physics and mathematics
when I say mathematics now I mean the
standard logic standard mathematics they
may differ in certain fundamental ways
where the mathematics that girdle was
using is subject to the incompleteness
theorem but physics may not be okay
Steven Spencer asks why is string theory
still a thing well Steven I'm not sure
what you mean by a thing but I think
what you mean is why it's still a theory
that we take seriously I'm gonna
interpret it that way and the answer to
that question is because string theory
has and continues to have remarkable
success in being able to do a number of
things that we physicists consider to be
very important among them we're able to
put gravity and quantum mechanics into a
consistent mathematical theory we're
able within string theory to see how
basically every achievement of the past
hundred years can actually fit within
the edifice of string theory the things
I have in mind just to be slightly
technical are things like to gauge
theories that we know are able to
describe the fundamental forces that we
are able to measure in the world around
us the the Higgs fits within string
theory certain kinds of symmetries that
are necessary to ensure the stability of
the proton and things of that sort they
all not to fit all of the particles in
the standard model of particle physics
if I'm a natural home within the
structure of string theory and moreover
string theory gives us insights into
qualities of the world that we don't
know of any other way to get those
insights for instance into the nature of
black holes nature of black hole entropy
and and things of that sort so it's an
incredibly vibrant
and fruitful mathematical theory the
thing that we don't know and the thing
is what Stephen is pointing to is we
don't know if it actually describes our
universe or whether it's just a
beautiful mathematical edifice that will
develop and develop and develop but
never be able to test experimentally or
connect with observations of the real
world and those are vital and important
qualities and we hope that we will get
there we have not gotten there yet but
we're driven onward by the theoretical
successes that string theory has
achieved and those are deep and and
unassailable and that's why in the
language of the questioner Stephen
Spencer string theory is still a thing
so just I see on the on the feed here so
be sure would vids ask could we ever
test string theory following up on that
question and in principle yes we had
hoped that at the Large Hadron Collider
one of the qualities of string theory
the quality of supersymmetry which says
that there should be other particles
beyond the ones that we know about in
the world it's not what it says both
would be implications we'd hope to find
those particles at the Large Hadron
Collider by now and we and we have and
so am i disappointed about that sure
would have been really exciting to find
the supersymmetric particles the the
partner of the electron and the partners
of the quarks yeah that would be
incredibly exciting I mean speaking from
a personal perspective and many
physicists would tell a similar story
you know 90% of what I've worked on in
my professional career has made use of
the mathematics of supersymmetry this
this additional symmetry that we that we
imagine nature might actually obey it's
a symmetry that connects particles of
different spins it gives a kind of
quantum mechanical extension of space
and time we have thought that we might
have evidence for that by now and we
don't
so am i disappointed by that yeah I'd be
honest I'm certainly disappointed by
that but I always end an answer like
this by saying I'm not
wedded to string theory I and if we
could prove it wrong that would be an
important step forward to so I'm open to
it being right I'm open to it being
wrong and I'm open to pursuing it until
we can judge and as of today we can't
yet judge because the scales at which
the theory distinguish itself from more
conventional approaches the energy
scales are so huge the lane skills are
so tiny that it's beyond today's
experimental reach but but that could
change tomorrow if we if we get lucky
okay so guido asked right now what is
the physical interpretation of imaginary
numbers and another one Eric Weinstein
is geometric unity lecture are you
familiar with so I'll guess I'll do both
of those so for imaginary numbers
imagined numbers are a curious thing we
all learn about them in high school or
before we all learn that you know to
take the square root of a negative
number you can't do that in the usual
real number system that we learn as
we're growing up so we have to extend
the real number system to include
imaginary numbers where I is defined to
be the square root of negative one and
the question is do you need those kinds
of numbers to actually describe the
external world and you know the answer
is both yes and no you can always
reformulate any mathematical equation
any law that involves real and imaginary
numbers complex numbers you can always
reformulate it cleverly in terms of two
copies of the real numbers one that goes
in the ordinary direction that we
learned since we were born and the other
that goes in a separate direction which
would count for the imaginary values but
combining them into a complex quantity
by using the standard formulation a plus
IB take those two real numbers a and B
and combine them into one complex number
is incredibly efficient and useful
especially when you get to Schrodinger's
equation in quantum
I don't know how many of you looked at
the little vidi was a little on the
technical side it's called the
generalized Schrodinger equation I don't
remember which one it was your daily
equation number I don't know 13 I don't
know don't hold me 12 or 13 something
like that and if you look in there in
the beginning of that I described why it
is that in stro dagur's equation there
is an i right and those of you who have
not studied quantum mechanics may not
know this but the fundamental equation
of quantum mechanics has an imaginary
number sitting right there
IH bar d sy DT why is there an I there
and I explain that there that it's the
really the only way that we can get this
wave function to satisfy a certain
equation that's motivated by physical
considerations so it's not as though you
have a device for a meter that measures
you know three times I as a length or a
time or an energy it's always a real
number that our meters measure but
packing them I should say packaging them
in this imaginary complex manner is both
powerful and and deeply connected to the
quantum nature of the world okay what
else do we have here
hello mr. green Jiminy Cricket I have a
feeling that it may not be your name but
Jiminy Cricket says I'd like to know can
you please explain the expansion of the
universe from the perspective of time
since space-time is a single thing is it
not and and yes space-time is meant to
be a single thing and if you do look at
it as a single thing then it that
perspective I should say doesn't itself
has it does not have a temporal
characteristic if you're looking at all
of space throughout all of time you've
got the whole thing right there and the
only way to see a temporal unfolding is
to cut it up it's like a it's like a
movie right when you have a movie you've
got the the whole movie reel in front of
you there's no unfolding there's no
passage from the beginning of the film
to the end of film only when you take
the film and you put it in a projector
and allow it to unwind and you look at
the frame this moment after moment after
moment is there a temporal quality
to that film similarly take the entire
universe it's like the whole reel of
film the only way you get a temporal
quality is to slice it up all of a space
at one moment all the space at the next
moment all the space at a third moment
and so forth and in that slicing it up
depending on how you do the slicing you
can see that the size of space grows
over time your first slice space is tiny
the next slice space is expanded it's a
little bit bigger and so forth on down
the line so you sort of can have your
cake and eat it if you're gonna have the
full spacetime perspective then
space-time is just off thing if you want
to see space expanding you've got to
take that thing and divide it up into
movie frames and in the movie friends
you can see that the size of space
increases over time and Patterson asks
you just take a quick water as I'm
reading this one and Patterson says do
you think consciousness is a product of
quantum mechanics is there a universal
consciousness permeating all matter so I
don't I do not think that well let me
take a step back I'm reading into your
question and Patterson I think that
consciousness is a physical process and
physical processes are all quantum
mechanical so do I think that
consciousness emerges from quantum
mechanics in that sense absolutely but
usually when somebody asks me this
question they're thinking of it in a
somewhat more how should I say I don't
mean this in sort of a denigrating way
but a more kind of Wu sense like the
weirdness of quantum mechanics and the
weirdness of consciousness they all kind
of blend together and that's really
what's going on so I don't think that's
true I don't think that the weirdness of
quantum mechanics gives us any insight
into the mysteries of conscious
awareness beyond quantum mechanics
giving us an understanding of how the
particles and how the forces move and
come together and coalesce and in that
way I think yield the macroscopic
phenomenon that yields conscious
awareness now do I think that there's a
universal consciousness permeating
all matter I don't i don't i think
consciousness only emerges when you have
a certain collection of particles
organized in an appropriate manner
allowing them to carry out a certain
kind of information processing and
that's when I think consciousness
emerges I do not think if there's some
consciousness field that we're all sort
of floating within and our our minds are
kind of tapping into that consciousness
field that is something that many people
do think about or like David Chalmers
you know his view and others sort of
this view that particles themselves may
have conscious awareness at some proto
conscious level it's an interesting idea
I don't see any evidence for it and I'm
not drawn to that solution to this whole
hard problem of consciousness doesn't
mean that it's wrong it just means that
it's not something that resonates with
me at my level of understanding
James Burke Weston asked just right now
is consciousness a form of entanglement
and Marge leaf asks on YouTube are all
particles in the universe entangled and
I do not well again it's an interesting
thing I'm about to say no but then I
have to take a step back are the
particles in my brain entangled at some
level they are when particles interact
and and coalesce in the right manner the
quantum mechanical description is such
that you can't talk about the particles
independently of the other particles
they blend together in a manner that
requires that you have a description of
the whole collection so so are the
particles in my brain at that level
entangled yes are the particles in my
brain responsible for my conscious self
awareness yes therefore is quantum
entanglement and my conscious self
awareness are they connected yes but
again I'm reading into the question that
was asked because it's often asked in
the matter of you know when you have
entanglement which is the very last your
daily equation that we do where a
particle over here and a particle over
here somehow are able to kind of talk to
each other through these invisible
quantum connections and that's the
notion of and
often people say well you know does that
mean that my brain and another brain can
be sort of talking to each other is that
sort of what coincidences are that our
brains are sort of somehow quantum
mechanically linked when the phone rings
and I was just thinking about Steve and
this Steve on the phone you know is
there some sort of entanglement that can
explain that coincidence and my entry
does not that's total nonsense
that's not what entanglement tells us
and it's not what our understanding of
consciousness tells us so in that sense
consciousness has nothing to do with
entanglement but fundamentally of course
it does and then to Martha's question
are all particles in the universe
entangled if particles have had some
causal interaction you know if they've
come together at some point in the past
then their quantum mechanical state is
influenced by that and therefore in some
sense they are entangled
but the entangled the degree of
entanglement let you say become so
suppressed over time that your
description of the particle is
individual and not dependent on some
distant particle that it may have
interacted with billions of years ago is
so accurate that thinking about them
entangled becomes ever less useful but
yet at some fundamental level or any
particles that have had some interaction
are they entangled yes let's see what we
got here so honest Feisal asks what is
something unique in string theory that
other theories of unification of physics
don't have and yeah I already sort of
said a few words about string theory but
but the big thing net string theory has
is on paper it puts together general
relativity and quantum mechanics into a
consistent mathematical formalism we're
able to do calculations that blend
quantum mechanics and gravity and that's
something that most theories cannot do
it's not the only theory that claims
that loop quantum gravity would make a
similar claim and there are many reasons
why I think that string theory is the
more promising approach but in terms of
distinctive quality
that we would we would you know light up
the sky with if we were trying to market
string theory as to why we think it's
valuable it's because it puts grabbing
quantum mechanics together into a
consistent mathematical story let's see
Carsten vidi-vidi asks from YouTube our
equations invented or discovered I did
say a few words about this I think in
episode 1 of your daily equation but I
did say there I think or at least I on
occasion said that my view on this
question changes sometimes daily right
there some days I think that equations
are discovered some days are invented so
Carsten it's good to check in frequently
to see what what my perspective is on it
now but but you know less facetiously
for a while I've been thinking more and
more that equations are invented not
discovered more and more it seems to me
that we humans are really good at
identifying patterns in the world around
us that's in essence how we survived
right we survived by virtue of being
able to understand the repeatable
aspects of the world allowing us to gain
control over them and when we then use
our mathematics we can encapsulate the
patterns of the external world and in
that way we develop this language that's
really good at capturing patterns and
then some of us go further and say let's
just look at the language of patterns
let's look at the mathematics itself and
divorce it separate it from the external
world and go off into these abstract
realms of mathematical discovery and I
use the word discovery in the sense of
discovering the patterns that the
mathematics is able to describe as
opposed to discovering equations that
are out there just sitting around saying
wow I'm a really nice theorem one of
these human mathematicians gonna find me
I sort of don't think that's how it is I
think it's this thing inside of our
heads it's able to find the patterns
describe the patterns and use mathematic
to articulate them
okay Nix asks Brian are we any nearer to
explaining the faster-than-light
implications of entanglement in terms of
an actual mechanism and there was
another one that just went by on youtube
I went by too fast but somebody was
asking you know how close are we to an
explanation of entanglement and I guess
I would say we have a complete and total
explanation of entangle totals always a
strong word to use in physics let me
pull that back we have a robust that's a
nice word a robust explanation of
entanglement in the formalism of quantum
mechanics it's not like we have particle
over here and particle over here and the
correlation between their properties
shuttle's us when you measure this one
you get spin up and you measure this
when you get spin down that's completely
in keeping with the mathematical
prediction of quantum mechanics so what
we then try to do is we say look here's
the math it predicts this quality we go
out we measure it it confirms that
quality and then we set ourselves how do
we gain an intuition for this weirdness
that you do something over here you
measure this particle that seems to
affect the state of this particle over
here we we hunger to have an intuition
but our intuition was framed it was
developed over thousands of generations
of our forebears struggling to survive
and our intuition thus is very good at
doing certain kinds of things I mean
look at this right I mean if I look at
me what I can do here I throw this up I
catch it I throw it up I catch it again
I throw it up because that's not easy if
you think about it what you say that's
totally trivial but you know if I do
something like this right I did catch it
for me to calculate the power Baalak
motion of this complex floppy object
it's a coaster flying through the space
and then able to put my hand in the
location in space where that floppy
object will be then that would be a
complicated calculation I don't need to
calculate though right
my intuition is so good at the basic
physics of the external world that I can
just Intuit where to put my head as can
all of you because we are the
beneficiary
of a long history of evolutionary
survival where survival depended on
being able to do those kinds of things
so the point is our intuitions good for
things that affect our survival
entanglement in quantum mechanics not
among the things that in the
evolutionary past distinguished between
who live and who died in fact you can
imagine that those of our forebears who
kind of sat down on a fallen branch to
contemplate Schrodinger's equation and
electrons and neutrinos back in the
ancestral past they did not pay
attention when that lion was approaching
and they got eaten right so so not only
is quantum mechanics not evolutionarily
useful it probably was evolutionarily
challenging to anybody who thought up
these ideas of course I'm being
facetious but the point is our intuition
isn't good and therefore we struggle to
explain how something here affects
something over here but physics doesn't
need to accommodate our limited
intuition and you do something here and
effects something here it comes right
out of the mathematics and it's not
faster-than-light in the sense of any
information going from here to there if
you wanted to send a signal using
quantum entanglement in the your daily
equation episode I had a particle in New
York of particle in California to
measure it in New York it's up then you
know the one in California is down but
how would you send a signal you don't
have any control over one in New York
turns out to be up or down therefore you
have no control over whether the one in
California is down or up you just have a
correlation that correlation only
becomes available to you when you
compare the two and that's slower than
like comparison and therefore there's no
information that travels from one place
to another faster than the speed of
light even with quantum entanglement so
we have the mechanism it's basic quantum
mechanics it's the intuition that we try
to develop all right what else do we
have here oh man there's so many good
questions racing by they race by so fast
I sometimes can't even read them
um let me go to this one I can see Jason
faults asks well I know that's a good
question but I'm not sure I'd say but
how do you feel about the idea that our
universe exists on the surface of the
four-dimensional black hole I think
Jason is talking about this idea
pellagra fee holography is this this
weird idea that is now becoming part of
the standard description of the world
for those people who think about things
in quantum mechanics gravity and string
theory it's the idea that you can have a
three-dimensional environment surrounded
by a two-dimensional surface and a
two-dimensional surface like a hologram
can coat all the information in the
three-dimensional environment similarly
you can go up and imagine that you know
four space-time worlds such as ours
right it may have a holographic dual as
well and and it's a very strange idea
when you imagine that there's a
alternative description to our world in
principle that doesn't look like our
world doesn't have the sort of the three
dimensions of space that we are familiar
with but that is one of the ideas that
naturally emerges from our studies of
unified theories there's people like
Lenny Susskind and Gerardo tuft and and
folks who've been developing these ideas
further and how do I feel about this
possibility though we are living in a
holographic universe well I my opinions
are driven by the mathematics and the
mathematic suggested as a real
possibility so I consider it to be an
exciting field to explore and many
people are doing just that all right
what do we got here another quantum
entanglement shubik mundo how does
quantum entanglement takes place is a
violin specialty relative pretty much we
answered that it doesn't violate special
theory to be no information goes faster
than the speed of light praiano xu asks
from india similar can information
travel with the speed which is faster
the speed of light
considering quantum tamah good we're all
heading down the same pathway no it
cannot nothing goes faster than the
speed of light in the sense if nothing
goes through space carrying information
at
speed that exceeds the speed of light
let's see Blaine Driscoll asks once one
particle is measured with a 50/50 chance
of having a certain spin the
corresponding particle is a hundred
percentage having how good this is again
a good I'm people watching the
entanglement video so yes if you've got
two particles each with a 50/50 chance
of being up-and-down and if they are
entangled and if the entangled state is
such that when this is up this is down
and when this is up this is down you go
over to the particle in my right hand
you measure it you find that it's up
then the one in my left hand no longer
has a 50/50 chance of being up-and-down
that exactly is a point you've hit the
nail on the head it now is a hundred
percent chance of being down that's the
sense in which the quantum state has
been changed before you do the
measurement 50/50 up down in both hands
do the measurement here know that it's
up the state here is now different the
state here now says 100% down that no
doubt as Blaine says in the question no
doubt that it is 100%
okay so lamia asks string theory
predicts that excellent good string
theory class string theory predicts that
extra dimensions are imperceptibly small
but spatial dimensions point line square
cube follow a pattern of being ever
larger in layman's terms why would 4d
why would more than four D dimensions be
small if sort of the easy intuition that
as you go up in dimensions things get
bigger and you have to be a little bit
careful with what you mean by big and
small when talking about spaces of
different dimensions I I totally get
Lani of what you're talking about you
know I could yeah maybe even just bring
this up on the screen what the heck see
if this actually works so when you're
talking about say something that has
zero dimensions right what you're
talking about is a dot right there it is
if you then go to a space that has one
dimension it kind of looks like this so
you'd say it's kind of gotten bigger and
then if you go to two dimensions you
know you could go like this and sorry
I'm being a little bit sloppy with my
drawing here all right so so your
intuition might be Lani as you suggest
that as you go from a point zero
dimension to one dimension to two
dimension things are getting bigger but
when we talk about size in the
dimensions we're talking about sort of
the spatial length to cross the object
as opposed to comparing literally a 2ds
shape to a 1d shape to zero dimensional
safe so when we say that a shape is
small what I really mean is that the
distance to cross it in sort of any of
these dimensions is a small length
compared to the length of everyday life
so for instance in string theory when we
have say six dimensional spaces I can't
really draw one but when we say that
it's very small we mean that this
distance over here might be on the order
of say 10 to the minus 33 centimeters
whereas in everyday life or the things
that we can see with our eyes you know
we can see things on the order you know
100 centimeters that's a meter using a
microscope you know we can get down you
know 10 to the minus 6 meters using
Large Hadron Collider you can get to
maybe 10 to the minus 18 meters but this
number 10 to the minus 33 is much
smaller than any of those and it's in
that sense that we mean that the extra
dimensions are small it's that sense as
opposed to comparing shapes of different
number of dimensions so it's a different
measure of big and small that we bring
to bear okay objects is the speed of
light
only applicable for visible light or
does it remain constant for the entire
electromagnetic spectrum that's
important point it's it's it's for the
entire electromagnetic spectrum the
equations that we use to describe like
Maxwell's equations which I'll get to
probably in episode you know 846 of your
daily equation right it'll be awhile
before we get there if ever but the
equations that Maxwell wrote down they
apply to light of any frequency so those
equations don't say hey here's how light
of a certain wavelength or frequency
behaves and here's how light of a
different wavelength and corresponding
frequency behaves the beautiful thing
about Maxwell's equation it treats the
entire electromagnetic spectrum in the
same way and within that equation we
manifestly can see that disturbances to
the electromagnetic field which is what
we mean by electromagnetic radiation it
travels through a vacuum at the speed of
light regardless of its wavelength or
its frequency okay what else have we got
here
does Oh Coco asks Professor Brian what
in your opinion is the most fundamental
problem with the local education system
where you are from okay slightly
different question not a not a technical
science one but an important one yeah so
I can equip you a quick answer to that
Coco and and my view is that in much of
our educational system at least here in
the United States and part of the
education system that I've come into
contact with there is too great a focus
on assessment there's two great of focus
on quizzes and tests there's too great
of focus on being able to measure
students understanding and to rank them
in the different levels of understanding
and aptitude I think it's far more
important to get kids excited about
these ideas to get them to want to learn
the ideas not because they're afraid
they're gonna fail an exam but to get
them to want to learn the ideas because
they are the most wondrous spectacular
ideas that we as a species have been
able to develop and it's not easy to get
kids to that place you're competing with
so much else in the world a little less
now than in the past but there's so many
distractions that the world offers and
learning especially learning in math and
science can take a concerted effort and
exerting that effort can be off-putting
or difficult but I tell you I've spoken
to kids and I've found the way in on
some of them to say hey think about
black holes and I describe here think
about the big bang and I described or
think about quantum mechanics that I
describe it and and that approach to get
their excitement revved up can work and
if the educational system focused more
on that as opposed to assessment I think
it would in the end be more effective
okay so what else do we have here Nina
Chan asks what is the end of life well
look what is the end of life it's the
ceasing of the molecular processes that
support certain kind of biological
processes that we define as life you
know when I die the moment after I die
you know my assuming that you know it
isn't some violent death my my particles
will more or less be intact they simply
will no longer be able to carry out the
choreographed processes that allow me to
have conscious awareness and allow me to
take in and process ingredients from the
environment from air to food and so
forth I like to describe it as a dance
of entropy we living beings are able to
dance what I call the entropic two-step
where we are able to keep our order nice
and high
our disorder lower entropy low even
though the tendency from the second law
of thermodynamics is for systems to go
toward ever greater disorder and we're
able to dance that dance where we keep
our order nice and high or disorder low
by virtue of eliminating disorder to the
wide the wider environment and that's
the dance I'm talking about keep our
entropy low by giving off heat waste to
the environment making its entropy grow
larger and there's a point in every
living systems existence where they're
no longer able to dance the entropic
two-step and that's really when entropy
wins and they fall apart life in that
sense ceases if you're interested you
can check out and I don't mean this as
an advertising because I hate that kind
of nonsense but I have a book until the
end of time just came out get it from
the library don't buy it but in there
there's there's a discussion of the
entropic two-step and in that sense the
distinction between life and death from
the standpoint of physics okay so what
else do we have time for yeah I've got a
few more minutes before the hour is up
somebody just has why did the
higgs-boson freeze god of course you
went by too fast can i scroll back that
yes I can where is that question I like
that question but I don't see it any
longer oh that's too bad
somebody asked a nice question about the
Higgs boson oh well but I I think I know
what it says I can't give your name
because I went by mm but why did the
Higgs field permeates space you see our
view is that cosmologically doesn't have
to be this way but but the most
prominent theories suggest that early on
in the history of the universe this this
cosmic molasses that we call the higgs
field remember is discovered in
experiments at CERN July 4th 2012 big
announcement the Higgs particle was
found that gave us evidence for this
mathematical idea that we are immersed
in a bath of molasses invisible we feel
it in the sense that when we try to push
on fundamental particles like electrons
and quarks they resist our push what's
that resistance the resistance is those
particles are being slowed down pulled
back if you will by this Higgs field
this cosmic molasses but the belief is
cosmologically that early on the
universe was not filled with this Higgs
field instead as the universe cooled it
went through what we call a phase
transition you're familiar with those
from water freezing into ice so you can
have an ice vat of water and as you cool
the water it suddenly goes through a
change of phase from liquid to solid
from liquid water to solid ice we think
the same thing happened in the universe
early on the higgs field had not
condensed if you will into this molasses
but as universe cooled down then the
Higgs was able to go through this phase
transition and yield this molasses this
nonzero vacuum expectation value in the
language of mathematics that permeate
spacing gave mass to particles so early
on that would mean that any particles
that were floating around they would
have had no mass because there wouldn't
have been any Higgs field to draw them
back all right a few more questions
before we wrap it up here
let's see Michael O'Brien asks from
YouTube how can or Twitter I'm not sure
which now how can science reductionism
even in theory solve the hard problem of
consciousness consciousness question
those are fun tasks if you somehow
mapped out every synapse molecule
particle in the brain associate with
conscious sensation it still wouldn't
answer how and why these configurations
create consciousness and Michael I get
where you're coming from totally I mean
that is the hard problem of
consciousness the view that no matter
how much you know about the ingredients
you'll never be able to talk about the
inner sensation of conscious awareness
the idea being science can only ever
tell us about the objective third-person
accessible qualities of particles or
master spin their charge their energy
and so forth and none of that ever
speaks to the inner quality so no matter
how much you know about the external
quality you'll never eliminate the inner
quality and I get that I get that but my
my suspicion is that the distinction
we're drawing between inner and outer is
too sharp I think that five years a
hundred years a thousand years now turn
the whole I'm will take I think that we
won't draw that distinction we'll
recognize that there are qualities of
particles period end of story
internal external don't even need to
commit myself and when those particles
come together according to the laws that
govern their interactions there is a
quality of consciousness that those
particles are able to build through
their collective motion and we won't
call it internal we won't call it
external we'll just call it this is how
the world works and we will understand
it at a sufficient level that we feel
satisfied that this hard problem is no
longer hard and no longer even a problem
now
I can't do that nobody can do this so
I'm not in right now speaking from the
standpoint of the answer I'm guided in
my thinking by for instance what
happened with the phenomenon of life
there was a time when life was so darn
mysterious that the view was lifeless
particles can never come together to
yield a living system
most of us don't feel that way any
longer because as we've understood life
better we've recognized
it's just processes that are highly
highly organized and coordinated I think
we'll get to a point when consciousness
will also see that as a process emerging
from highly coordinated highly
choreographed motion of particles John
Majora's asks in your opinion what is
the most astounding fact that you can
tell us about the universe that's that's
a good question
and also stand in fact well look I mean
I'm astounded by many facts I'm
astounded by the equations of general
relativity how how utterly beautiful it
is that they're able to describe the
warps and curves in the fabric of space
and how spectacular it is that those
warps and curves do describe how planets
and stars move I mean that is astounding
I'm astounded by quantum mechanics that
we have this totally counterintuitive
perspective on the world using waves of
probability of all things and we have
this equation called the Schrodinger's
equation and and it governs how these
waves of all over time and the
probabilistic predictions are borne out
by observation astounding but if you ask
me for the most astounding fact quality
of the world of all I would say it is
that we're here that we conscious beings
are here that somehow the chain of
quantum processes reaching back to the
Big Bang and until today conspired not
through any guiding intelligence I do
not believe but the laws alone somehow
gave rise to these exquisitely organized
collections of particles called life
whether it's autumn aus or an amoeba or
a human being life emerged from the
quantum mechanical laws of nature and
moreover these collections called human
beings they're endowed with conscious
self-awareness so yes going back
- the hard problem that was being asked
before by whoever was asking about
whether we'll ever answer the hard
problem of consciousness whether we
answer it or not we know that we're here
and we know that we emerged through the
laws of guidance that the universe
somehow is endowed with and that to me
is the most spectacular fact the most
spectacular an astounding quality of
reality and you know what do you do with
that well you know we don't talk much
about the reason why I started the
series or why you all are at home right
now right we're all in the midst of this
awful pandemic tragic where people are
dying and and there's so much pain and
suffering that's spreading throughout
the world and nothing can ameliorate
that but I do find a certain sense of of
solace and a certain feeling of
reverence for the fact that we are here
at all doesn't take away the pain but it
does allow you to pull back and
recognize how astounding it is that life
even exists and just really for me makes
me appreciate the fact that for a brief
moment in time I'm here and and and and
I hope that that's something that some
of you can take away with because it's
something that we all should be deeply
gratified by and something that we
should all be deeply thankful for all
right that is the end of the hour that
concludes this live session remember if
you kind of like these things and
material of creating I think there's a
little subscribe button right subscribe
go ahead no world science festival
creates all sorts of content that I
think you would enjoy engaging with next
time for next Friday I'll try to do this
again I never know exactly what the
schedule is gonna be but so far we've
been relatively regular in the offerings
that we have been giving and if you'd
like to submit a question in video
format that's always fun make it sort of
20 30 seconds don't go on for five
minutes a little hard to use I think
there's instructions in the description
to this live session for how you do that
but yeah submit a video question
can join me in that virtual manner with
your question I'd be happy to address
them so so go ahead go do that okay
other than that I'm gonna pick it up
with your daily equation I'm gonna do a
fun one on Monday I'm pretty certain I'm
gonna do it on where the Planck length
and Planck time and Planck scale very
simple mathematics but people often ask
where do those numbers come from where
does 10 to minus 33 centimeters of the
Planck length come from very very simple
but it's fun to just sort of see it
worked out once I think that that's what
I'll do next time but you never know who
may be inspired to do something else
until then take care it's been fun
addressing your questions and keep them
coming and I'll try to address as many
as I can next time that I didn't get to
today all right
that's Brian Greene signing off take
care